all right
it's 11:11 I was about to make a wish
but now it's 1112 right when I said that
at the time changed anyway I'm gonna do
some viewer challenges I really have two
pending challenges I posted on my stream
schedule I would do viewer challenges
today so let's accept rocky wait what
Oh a new game started because I'm
watching the top game I can still accept
rocky ok playing rocky five-minute game
is rated 1305 hopefully things look ok
you shift this over a little bit and
let's play chess let's play something
new
let's place candy and instead of Queen
take I'll play Knight f6 different
approach not about opening for blitz
actually usually leads to easy
development at the highest levels white
gets some edge Knight takes d5 was a
mistake by White's because now black is
just dominating the center and I'll
continue to control the center with a
multitude of pieces hello to people in
the chats Jabara I am playing viewers
query Oh super major pain or McGowan
Kinsey boy saying I'm a chess god at
first I thought you said I'm a chest dog
well okay d3 let's play v control space
pour some tea I started a little bit
late or later than planned because I
forgot to make tea but now I'm making
tea and the tea has been made now I'm
pouring the tea okay
my opponents still thinking I'm almost
up a minute on the clock or only on move
seven but it's already slightly less
preferable for whites expecting like
Bishop developing or castling tempted to
queenside castle it's a little bit
committal but the defiles half open I
would like to play some pawn advance on
the Kings side I got five left for c-4
is a move c4 it kind of invites this
there should be four Bishop d2 we trade
maybe bit should be for Bishop d2 Queen
a5 the drawback of c4 is d3 is now just
a kind of a permanent weakness so
backward pawn I'll have full control
over the d4 square and we might trade
some things but that's not going to fix
the weakness I'm attacking me too I'm
expecting Queen d2 we could trade a
little bit more
I think I'm winning a pawn actually
first of all Queen takes Queen is a
mistake because I taken Knight c2 and if
that I think I can just take up a clean
pawn yeah that d3 pawn did not last for
long and we have a sub which is slightly
hidden let me move this slightly over
Thank You a far saying okay so like
castles now it's the matter of technique
it's double rooks only open file at some
point the night might want a maneuver or
it might want to fork the Majestic fork
Knights has appeared what are the odds
that I'll end up back rank meeting I
could rook here it takes takes and I'll
play like efore Bishop a4 interesting so
let's take this which defends my rook
this is looking pretty winning I'll play
this I'm threatening this I'm fighting
this if this I do this okay let's take a
pawn Kenzi boy repeating himself the
second time you use you're saying you're
a chess god yeah I saw it the first time
if anyone's a chess god it's God okay
let's play g6 and play a five and it's
bits from oh so G oh thanks oh so G oh
that's a new name and hello to more
people
moon tongue just add blue just add blue
I don't think I've ever adopted you so
you don't have to call me your dad I
guess you can do what you want
interrupting your guitar practice my
deepest apologies okay so I'm gonna go
for like the traditional plan rooks on
the seventh or the second in this case
how long to get to 22,000 rating depends
how hard you're willing to work
also depends on like Oh my opponent
resigns like ratings don't come
overnight and sometimes they come in
like bursts takes a lot of patience my
opponent sure that if at least tried
that for trying like babe me into
getting maybe okay would not have
happened so good game ronke I have a lot
of challenges I mean I play this guy
because he was the second person to
challenge me I think also rocky with a
sub this happened the previous stream to
where like I beat someone and they then
they sub to me and Rio with a sub but
actually the previous stream well it's a
message not sure about your status as a
deity but I appreciate your videos work
education have learned a lot from your
videos and your talks keep it up well
thanks for the message let's play a
normal French like normally I play
Bishop f4 also I forgot my stream title
says I'm taking opening recommendations
but I don't think anyone has recommended
an opening also just add blue gifting 5
subs that was unexpected and generous
thanks just add blue unlike the previous
stream I that's like small enough for me
to read off the names we have the wood
layer we have hooch sll we have soul sin
threes I just pronounced as E's we have
Scott 1 3 6 9 we have the Punisher 2884
that's the high rating and we have even
a ver ik welcome to the sub club so I'm
playing the tirage which is actually one
of the very first openings I ever
learned my first coach taught it to me
and this is one of the main lines Locke
has two moves here Queen takes and pawn
takes play Knight f3
for my experience in this line like half
the time against amateur level players
black isn't quick enough to Castle and
I'll get a rook to e1 before black and
castle and then things can be very good
so playing this line is black it's
important to be precise there should be
seven this is a new position for me I
usually block starts with knight c6 I'm
not Knight f6 I'm thinking about just
Queen e2 and then if Bishop e7 I can
take and win upon seems greedy but a
pawn is a pawn I mean other options just
to take but that seems like it's only
helping black so let's play Queen you to
Queenie 7 ah so now if I take I lose a
piece which would be tragic
I could play 95 this interesting move
avoiding the Queen trade that actually
looks principled because if I play 95
it's actually a pawn sack but then the
Queen locks the bishop which box the
King let's play 95 and then very soon
I'll castle
Wow a six so wants me to trade so the
light can come into the game I could
consider taking the bishop wait this
actually looks really nice
or does it I take the bishop Queen takes
takes takes we're just trading if I take
the bishop with my bishop Knight takes
and maybe Knight f3 feel like White has
some advantage here just trying to
figure out how to optimize it I think
this is a mistake because the c4
question is what do I take on d7 with
let's just take with the bishop and then
then I'll go for a negative three and
this still might be a pawn sack like
black can just take and then I'm
probably castling and again like this
configuration my blacks gonna be slow to
Castle unless he wants to Castle
queenside that looks very risky and
hello two more people
oh do we have some opening
recommendations nilesy wants a Grob
opening maybe we make a list and just
make a list so I don't forget it's open
up a note thing that way I'll have I
typed in grab on my phone and a
connector autocorrected to grin wants me
to play the green opening where I just
play moves and slightly smile 94 it's
interesting move not sure what that does
94
I could still castle Ella's castle now
you for might prepare f6 but okay I
think I have a threat here and probably
threatening to take and in ig5 and doing
stuff okay so we have more opening
suggestions we have gob connected
autocratic corrected to grown grout
there we go
Cambridge Springs a classic plays f6
yeah let's to me I mean I could take and
play 92 and then just go after the night
and threading f3
we have bird opening I think G for ELISA
coat according to most engines is a
worst possible first move also as f3
just winning a piece this is funny cuz
Ben Feingold says never playoff 3 never
playoff 6 but ok f 6 was probably a
mistake
f 3 was is just this very strong move so
I think it's always playoff 3 whoa this
is gonna get spicy though look at these
pawns there's so magnificent I'm
actually tempted just to sack back and
again I could keep my Knights but what
else do I do maybe Knight c4 I could
play around the pawns and pretend they
don't exist like Santa okay I want to
play Knight e5 and then Bishop f4 and
then rook t1 then maybe someday c3 okay
let's start with 95 I'm threatening the
Queen there's also tactical threats of
this
there's also ideas of taking on i-5
there's also cool guy subbing 13 months
in a row that's just over a year thanks
cool guy okay so both queens are hanging
I mean I could take take take but then I
was a rook so I could play this wait I'm
in check I even realized I was in check
that's not good
wait that's really bad
my about to lose a queen for nothing it
took me a moment to see that okay now I
have to fight how do I survive work f2
but then takes and the problem is like
if I take the Queen like black remotes
and meets me if I play Bishop III I'm
losing a ton of material like Bishop III
takes takes takes with check takes with
check again takes my knight in the end
I'm down like a rock in addition okay so
sometimes this will happen in chess
where you blunder but you don't want to
rage quit yet I have to give up the
Queen Queen f2 or Queen e3
I think I've considered all the legal
moves of disappoints Queen it's like we
need three
I'll get the bishops slightly more
active square okay I have minor pieces
like after takes takes I am I mean I
have the only minor pieces on the board
not again black has only Queen on the
board I thankfully this is casual but
it's still serious there's a lot of
pride on the line
should I pre move this okay so maybe
he'll forget the Queen's attacks
probably not there's some idea like
Knight c4 and targeting b6 also the
Queen's tied down to the fighting this
pawn so like if Queen g5 I can just take
the pawn
that was the best move I was actually
really hoping that black didn't play
that move because all the Knights kind
of stuck I have to move the bishop to
defendants Bishop f4 Bishop d4 Carly
Bishop d4 if takes and hopefully I win
the C pawn eventually can't believe I
missed III like I was so focused on
getting my Knights another place and I
like I made the threat to let's block me
the stronger threat and this all
happened because I played f3 yeah maybe
I was wrong castling queenside was
slightly unexpected but playable I could
play c3 played Bishop c3 probably c3
I have my chain of stuff Black has his
chain of stuff now this is going to be a
difficult position to survive because
major pieces are better than minor
pieces it's not a bad move there's
actually a trick here takes takes okay
I'm gonna start with this there's a few
tricks trick number one is I want to do
this trick number two
hey it's bits trick number two is if
takes takes takes I have this and I went
back a queen
I'd still probably be losing the endgame
but okay Black has to be careful a
little bit and there's ideas of this
block aiming this is a very menacing
pawn chain I'm dreaming of some like
mating idea like I get my bishop to this
diagonal he plays rook to e8 and then
like somehow Knight b6 could be mates
maybe in an alternate universe God he's
thinking her that's the move not the
most terrifying move like I could play
b3 and things seem somewhat stable for
being down a queen
minor pieces are defended III is under
control which is important
Wow
so he wants to play g5 and pawn storm I
would like to do this but I hang v3
there so I'm thinking about this and
then this and then the rook could just
get stuck also kind of touching f5 like
if if I get in see for the rook has to
kind of stay guarding the pawn it then
at four okay five I have before I
control like all the squares on the
fifth rank that I'll win the pawn
so the minor pieces they're doing work
I'm definitely not unemployed also
wondering if I could trap the rook in
the line like here there's also rugby
for and that case of Ricky got trapped
another case rook a five bishops III
rook c5 now that what kind of escapes
see for a cure before right here and
Bishop a three or a cure game of cat and
mouse okay but my time advantage is
growing with every second that passes
which is another element like to come
back from bad position sometimes you
have to use time as as a factor so I'm
gonna play c4 no need to think
look there now okay so this line is
actually happening in real life it's a
bit complex so cuz here here
counter-attacking I have 95 it's
interesting actually here here 95 say f4
I fork
a 4 is also a move but f4 is like so
obviously coming next
so I'll start with before I might even
just we not 5 get the rook active and
then maybe formulates a mating attack
here it takes I have my rook my bishop
my knight do something against the King
I don't want to lose my b4 claw probably
95 o 95 has another trick to it too but
it's a little bit hopeful so if it takes
rook takes rook c5 rook c5 then there's
Bishop e5 the positions still bad for me
I'm trying to create something here it's
also work out six ideas yeah let's take
position opens up a little bit now I no
longer ever have to worry about f4
coming
I spend a lot of time there but I think
it was worth it I want to play Rakesh
six next chases a queen away and then
eventually play Knight d5 and really
just start controlling more squares in
Black's territory like 95 on the horizon
and there's a lot of fork possibilities
for example actually an example might
come so I'll hold off on giving any
examples I'm up on time again which is
nice
like the Queen doesn't have too many
squares like what's what are the options
these three squares and that's it and
probably against any of them I play this
interesting queenie it's okay let's have
an outpost is the rook trapped i think
that rook might be trapped so if he
moves here here I have Knight b6 and
I'll win material back a little bit of
material back yeah I'm feeling some
momentum you these pawns are still kind
of scary still two connected passers in
my territory but okay Brooke is attacked
the King will be a target very soon up a
minute on the clock now
well I forgot about that move it's
probably a good move because now my legs
pinned to my bishop and I can't take the
rook this would be interesting but then
this this would be interesting
rook af1 also may be playable but I
don't want to give lock time to play d2
my phone on silent takes I'm taking
doesn't really work here there's one
thing I'm concerned about which is if I
do this and there's like this move Queen
taking something about playing this
first and then doing this now there's
still it's still kind of a gamble okay
expecting rook III here we'll see what
happens okay I'm actually happy to see
Rick b3 I was more scared of Queen takes
d5 actually because now Brooke b6
and I think the rook is actually trapped
now and he can't take it because I fork
the king and queen so I actually don't
know what black does maybe there is
might be one move there's one move that
I see that's playable which I'm trying
to calculate
time is ticking after the game I'll look
at the opening suggestions and make a
list but I'm liking my chances to not
lose this game
yeah Queen aphorism of that I was
imagining to move that I would play so
it's still a fight my time is ticking
too
I could consider an eye here winning the
rook but then things get very messy
maybe play like rook b1
it's night their way this is actually
very complex and maybe just bad for me
my time is ticking to night here
I didn't really see much
I'd really didn't want to do that I'm
not left in my position anymore
but they're still like weird hope right
there it's too it's too this
time scramble time good move you check
check
only this is not good
Brooke t8 maybe coming I need a miracle
though okay oh that was a good move
actually I need a huge miracle
that was also a good move I think I'm
gonna lose this I fought so hard but in
the end it doesn't even matter is there
any sense in playing on bh3 always play
h3 creates safety for the king is a good
game well played
I was trying I don't know if I had
anything better
like Queen a4i I saw I should've started
calculating way beforehand maybe this
line was better try but it also seemed
very bad for whites GG I wasn't looking
at the chat too much do I want to look
at the chat
okay well maybe I'll do some quick
analysis okay laughing Gavin next game
okay I'm growing my opening list
laughing gambits yeah they gotta you
know okay let me catch up
Oh Scotch opening hyperaccelerated
dragon what happens if I take the rook
on b3 first and then fork the other rook
yeah so I'll try to do some analysis
first of all I should have seen d3 was
it in this position this is a danger
applying f3 like the king being a target
like huge Shauna was kind of a must the
black has compensation here according to
stock fish at least let me turn off
engine analysis and let's go back to I
think this was a question what if I do
this and then fork yeah this is probably
a better try but okay d2 and I can't
stop lock from cleaning I don't think
that's a problem like d2 happens in so
many of these lines hey we have a sub
wreck iam thanks for subbing when did I
lose a queen I'm already trying to
suppress the memory Sam you Slava
Phoenix system it's like the most
theoretical opening ever some you Slav
Botvinnik ok so I have a list of opening
recommendations go to move 3000 is a
three-bed do I have a better move here
Bishop c3 instead of a three
ah bishop c3 that makes a ton of sense
that's what I was trying to do as well I
don't know why I didn't feel like I
consider this I know why I would have
rejected it
yeah that's a great move because the
rook just has no squares and it's tied
down to b6 and my knight defends
everything it doesn't look like there's
counter play do you use your gift I'm
using it as we speak
as I speak what if I play Knight d6 and
set adrift b6 yeah I didn't want to
allow like ninety six wins material but
it simplifies and sometimes it's better
to keep pieces on the board rather than
simplifying hey it's $10 what's the
message to help ease the pain things are
these they appreciate its users of pain
slightly the best way to ease the pain
is tea and donations to I like to
torture low rated players not usually
but I mean sometimes okay no I'm gonna
use the $10 to buy more tea and not
painkillers let's let's move on let's
play another game
I did add Scotch gambit to the list
scotch
gambit okay so my list is now the Grob
Cambridge Springs Lockean Scotch opening
hyperaccelerated semi slot ball tunic
and scotch candidates I already played
the Scandinavian actually if you want to
see it you can go back in time I need a
better system for accepting challenges
let's play let's play an FM and are
there any wide openings
one white opening is a grab I'm playing
league Rob who suggested this agüero
saying the English opening I would have
played the English before playing the
grab but it's too late okay
I could play a scandi with g4 included
looks interesting
g4 probably hurts flight more than it
helps white but it does maybe restricts
Knight f6 and thanks Kaz 1337 for
subbing so this isn't your typical grub
then again grubs are just not typical
he's gonna play d5 so I think I have to
just kind of treat this seriously now
play objectively well it's more bits you
rock Eric keep up the good work and
stream more often well if you
incentivize me like that piano
wow that's another new name a few new
names
thanks piano Wow the last game was not
the best work and not my proudest work
so yellowdragon is thinking
I mean d5 look so obvious but again like
usually the normal way for blacks to
develop is moving the Knights but always
has to watch out for g5 if this were a
normal scan d1 pawn would still be on g2
so the added benefit is I also have this
move Queen h4 a while
I mean Queen h4 confuses me because it
looks like I can just develop with tempo
and my queen defends from a distance so
I'm actually pretty confused I mean
maybe he was just trying to like
scholars made me but I would have taken
a few moves in a row and wouldn't even
be maids I think the queen has to like
go back where it came from the moves to
f6 i Queen d8 because I've six I have an
attack it more so I have a few free
moves compared to normal scan D
trying to figure out how to develop and
ic3
just play Knight c3 means sometimes
white wants to play pawn to c3 but my
queen won't just get trapped so this is
essentially a Scandinavian but I'm up
three tempo or Tempe so black finally
developed something that's not his queen
what to do can we develop a bishop I
might even want a queenside castle at
some points this is a move 294 Bishop e6
there's also Queen e4 black wants to
play 97 I think I'll start with Bishop
g5 try and provoke and I'm trying to
provoke up 697 expected 95 in the air
Queen for castling as a move
Nikola queenside castle I guess I am
sacking upon I don't think black wants
to take the pond the bishop takes f2 I
probably have a III I'm castling
queenside because I'm actually prepared
to attack on the kingside like move one
I kind of made my intentions clear so d6
still looking at like these more
concrete continuations like here this
should be six like to generate more
initiative there's also this move which
is interesting I don't know if it does
much but it looks fancy a 94 this should
be 695 okay black wants to play - 57
wait 95 has a threat to it probably
Bishop d7 would be played and Queenie 4
actually looks quite nice because if I
get in Queenie 4 next for example Bishop
d7 Queenie 4 then all three of these
pieces are tied down to the night so
black wouldn't be able to castle and
it's not easy to remove like any of
these pieces
so maybe Blackwell castle right now f6
that can't be good maybe it's playable
or maybe it's good I don't know okay
have six
I mean first temptation is a sack takes
takes takes takes takes King f8 Queen uh
floor I don't think it works like
there's an IG 6 IG 696 h7 wait I'm
calculating mate actually takes takes
takes King f8 or f7 here here the night
h7 double check if King got something
I'd have Knight g5 so I double check
huge e7 o Queen R 6 isn't playable
I mean what's the normal move like
Bishop f4 it's so tempting though also
there's this other line so takes takes
takes King f8 Queen g4 knight c6 and
then Queen h6 came here I could have
Knight g5 King takes here goes back I
win the bishop I'm still down a piece
for two pawns takes takes takes okay
this line with Queen a for commas is
king g7 as well but then g5 I mean do I
go insane it's so tempting I'm doing it
blacks slightly underdeveloped I already
have my pawn energy for the pawn on g4
is meant to support a knight on f6
sometimes you just have to rely on
intuition
I don't thinking of seven makes much
sense because it's just asking for
Knight g5 at some points and the only
other legal move is King f8 so I should
keep got hit again King f8 Queen f4 96
Queen h6 King f7 g5 my queen is kind of
stuck I don't think there's there are
other options here
I mean queena for looks most enticing
could play g5 play Knight g5 attack h7
ah there's some interesting line like
Queen at 496 Queen age 1607 but I just
take on each seven so I'll have an IG
five coming okay I'm gonna do it's
blacks under pressure I'm down material
for the second game in the row not to
mention I am threatening like he's
double-checks I don't think they work
after 96 night g6 will only move that
I've been considering I mean there might
be other options never mind
so 97 doesn't lead to anything I don't
think it does it Kali King g7
ninety-two h7 King g7 again okay so
let's go for this going all-in it's like
poker king f7 that's what I was
expecting
now the question is I mean there's a few
options here I have this I have this I
have this I chief I probably doesn't
work g5 my queen got stuck g fiber than
h 5 h h4 h5 is interesting my time is
running low so if I take on h7 I have a
threat of Knight g5 to win this nights
and nights can start talking to each
other
hmm I'll see anything wrong with this
because I win upon I keep initiative I
weaken the defense of the Knights and
okay I mean the media idea is to do this
and in the Knights but then there's
other ideas if I have a couple moves I
have this idea and this idea so in a
rapid situation like even though I'm
down on time I think this is probably
just preferable for whites even if it's
still like objectively fine for black I
don't think it's easy to play for black
you just call me a knight whisperer that
would be a good TV show like the dog
whisperer whispering tonight's okay
Queen g8 interesting so defending and
counter attacking if I play this and
then King e8 I think my Queen's trapped
so I probably have to go all-in
further wait a minute if hear he need a
fork so Knight g5 yes to play Keaney
seven
Wow I don't see what else to do
I'm thinking h4 Oh a to z tact that's so
random I don't think that's a threat
though because I take on g6 we had Queen
g7 maybe I play this geforce also
hanging there's actually problems here
so the best approach is probably to
continue some momentum
maybe Bishop g2 access d5 that's why I
played g4 in the first place right sure
g2 interesting move okay I just assumed
black can't take on a to his Queen g7
and then wherever the King goes my
Knights come into play it probably just
meets if takes g4 bishop d5 and it's
nice because it's like if my bishop
lands on d5 I'm controlling like all
these squares in Black's territory and
I'll like when the Knights or the Queen
and it's not easy to fight for d5 can
maybe Bishop e6 will be played then
maybe I can consider f4 without a loud
Bishop III so Bishop e6 if I take that
my Knights stop talking to each other
such a confusing position I'm thinking
Bishop e6 I have bishop efore just
target the knights night there I forgot
about can I just play Bishop g5 pushing
d5 he wants to take on g4 such a mess
takes on g4 take some G it takes my h6 I
have nothing
so Bishop g5 takes on g4 Queen h3 maybe
may I could play h3 but it seems slow 95
was a very interesting move
maybe Bishop d5 takes and then Queen h5
and then Queen g7 and then h3 Knight
takes f2 no rook F 1 mm I might have to
go for it
time is ticking like h3 immediately
slows down anything else at for now
okay let's play Bishop g5 I'm being
sucked into the sign so takes G for
Queen h5 Queen g7 and my pieces are
swarming the King
yeah
so h3 no Ritchie one is interesting
player Chi one it's still very complex I
don't know who has initiative he has a
threat Maya make a threat he makes a
counter threat my king is still safer
than his game but my time is lower that
move I forgot about you I have to sack a
queen I have night derived queen up
three two I mean taking up six is also
interesting there probably bad so let's
do this uh he takes on each seven but I
have 24 okay I'm hoping one of these
lines works out let's take on each seven
first
maybe this no this is a problem
rook g5 is just such a random move just
like a panic move but okay at least I
have some idea I'm down to pieces but
his Kings on e7 I have six seconds left
Queenie for coming maybe this is Queen
h6 I think I have to play rook DG one
rook takes e5 also maybe an idea he's
kind of consolidating which is kind of
annoying 95 maybe Queen a4 it's probably
a good move
it's play Queen here now there's lots of
attackers on the Knights the problem is
my rooks pinned and I'm down to pieces
still so let's unpin now I'm threatening
this to win the Queen also some idea I
wanted to play at 4 of 1/2 pawns pinned
I'm also threatening this to win the
Queen King D sudden I still have work g7
so that's a move let's play b4 of before
it works but it's a move what's going on
here takes off - I want to deliver a
check and win the Queen let's do this
well I think there's a move that could
have killed me that move might also kill
me okay yeah the Queen trade is pretty
much just game over sadly also this move
oh my gosh this is not gonna end well
do I have any sort of nah
so much pain I resigned what a game I
was a incredible position I feel like
there was some even around here no no I
wanted to play this but 95 just defends
everything maybe I should play this
sooner but still 95
20 Knights defense yeah good game
yellowdragon I don't even know where to
start like analyzing I mean f6 is
probably the beginning actually g4 is
the beginning how many how many times
has this occurred on me chess the
specific position got to be less than
100 almost a thousand games what that's
an amazing thing about a chess is you
put in some like random position and
there's there's hundreds if not
thousands of games when White has a
decent score yeah Queen h4 is just bad
and then this was maybe questionable but
it was fun
I'll use stock fish coming up 95 I think
was a very good move at least like in a
practical sense and like I kind of
wanted to play each three but it just
seems slow and Bishop takes F to follow
that Bishop III thought it's just too
too much for black
so I think this is also a key moment
don't think I made the right decision
but then again it's very difficult just
cuz my queen is just stuck like all
these things are stuck even though
they're trying to attack they're clumsy
and they'd have sixes of threats so I'm
probably just worse here
let's check stockfish this is something
that sock fish will just crunch through
if you don't want to see the engine
evaluation and you want to close your
eyes or you want to UM study on your own
then you should close your eyes yeah
blacks just winning big time Mystics
it's funny because during the game I
didn't feel like I was -6 until a few
moves later is it just losing the whole
time what's this Akash think of the
night of 90 xf6
winning III is now the move I considered
Queen f4 okay sock fish is just confused
and says 11.1 up here it was saying +2
but now it changed its mind keeps
changing its mind
we found the position my computer just
doesn't understand like this number
doesn't really mean much like Bishop
what does Bishop g2 so Queen a4 it liked
at first it's funny and it's all up to
+2 and now it just says equal and now
it's better for black
wait what yeah sometimes this happens
with engines like you play out a line
and it'll just keep changing its
evaluation Queen g8 so this is all stuff
yeah and I'd see if I was very strong
and I was just losing good game okay I
think I'll play a quicker time control a
bishop efore instead of Bishop on side
Bishop g5 visually for I didn't consider
maybe it's a move stockfish still Knight
takes d4 cuz things fall in the end it's
still complicated even yeah Bishop takes
f2 is probably easier this is a monster
threats okay let's accept someone I need
a better system normally I try ask Siri
but there's too many I mean it's too
many people I think I said I would play
a quick game so let's play veneks
three plus two I'm on the losing streak
I lost two games in a row where's my
list of opening recommendations
laughing gambit accelerated dragon let's
play a laughs Ian if he plays Knight f3
relays line c3 I'll play a reverse Kings
gambit I don't know if this is a thing
but now it's the thing like it's just a
reverse Kings gambit this actually looks
kind of playable
and we have another sub-links concordia
n--'s 2019 do I want to take probably
not because then it would just
strengthen my Center now I want to play
this
turning the fork will trade open a file
I know I know there's people challenging
me I'm very aware asking me to accept a
challenge you need pretty good reason at
least at least for this frame there will
be it's just random I'll have some more
like fair system in the future okay so
I'm down upon the third game in the row
I'm down material but now I want my pawn
back now I'm winning another pawn easy
to forget
that's a file now there's some funny
trick if this and this and then this and
then I went on d4 so I don't think you
can take the d4 pawn anything better I'm
thinking about this mating ideas but
this looks good enough I could even take
on d4 right away looks very nice this is
easing the pain of the previous game
94 is coming wow what a fork I don't
know if I even want to take the Queen I
just resigned it's good time to resign
yeah the Knights they're just so fun if
there is a TV show called the knight
whisperer this would be a very good
episode
okay thanks FedEx for the game real
quick is this a real thing like I'm
curious if f5 is like a playable move
and master level play because I don't
see anything immediately wrong with it
it might just be that white has to move
like d4 sorry few things like tens of
thousands or over 10,000 games here
masters data days anyone play us nope
but sometimes interesting to like play a
dubious move and then try and figure out
the refutation d4 I'd you takes d4
squishy Hercules thanks for bits c4 e
takes d4 Queen Daisy for knight c6
there's probably like some king's gambit
theory where I think I can probably take
have Kings gambit up a tempo yeah I take
some g4 it's a bold approach but and
what if what if d v g5 Wow
isn't there some line where black socks
apiece it takes
I think still in a practical sense if
White's not sock fish and if white is a
thousand points lower rated then it
might be playable okay let's move on
another challenge I want to play this is
tiring it was very tiring let's play a
new name which one of these names looks
new this looks new Linna dart Oh dumb I
can't read line our detour whatever your
name is
good luck oh I should take another
opening suggestion okay I have one of
two openings in mind either Cambridge
Springs or a semi Slav Botvinnik I'll
play a semi Slav regardless against III
I can't really pay Cambridge Springs I
can't play that whatever it bought
fennec variation but we'll have a semi
Slav at Bishop e2 looks kind of slow the
main move is Knight c3
trying to figure out like if there's a
way to punish this or if I just have to
develop normally there should be two is
probably playable I think what I'll do
is I'll play well I would have played if
white play Knight c3 is this a six move
the idea is to take to play B 5 and then
c5 and I do waste time like playing c6
and then C five but white waste time
playing Bishop e2 and then taking then
Bishop b3 so let's play c5 we might
trade Queens and by no means it's black
better here but I think it's it's
equalizing equalizing is the first step
to getting some advantage as black maybe
c4 so Bishop e7 and c4 looks attractive
a4 is a good move
let's play c4
I get the bishop to be seven mice bishop
in these types of positions have a
comment from a Ouija she watch on
YouTube nice yeah I think more people
watch on YouTube and twitch post my
YouTube content is twitch streams let's
play Queen b6 musics is a normal way to
defend the pawn and they'll probably go
for Bishop d6 it's like the Danish
gambit but I'm knocked down material and
I have my amazing bishops a normally
white would like to play e4 in these
positions but II for might run into
before it could get messy the e4 before
Bishop a4 97
if I play z4 I'll start calculating Wow
actually I won't start calculating I'll
just move and hope it works because it
splits that's a move takes takes takes
takes Queen then Queen is there a line
where we both get Queens and we both
keep them if there is I'm going for it
that would be insane also thanks for
this new subs Kong Lord and mega
sneaking panda appreciate it
what is this takes takes wait okay I'll
start thinking after he takes on G
southern assuming he takes on g7
what's material I would be down the
exchange but I would have to Queens
but why would have to Queens what is
this I can't resist oh he takes on a
fate though what's still playable what a
position
like when they're when both sides have
two Queens like normal principals don't
always apply like the fact that all I
could be down to exchange isn't the
worst thing ever it's more about like
getting to the king and this Bishop it's
still like a sniper just hiding in the
corner this is rated to to take this
seriously
after we keep our Queens on the board ah
doesn't want to have fun okay so now
it's just equal material like after
Queen Jake c1 but it's very imbalanced
my kings in the center but I have a
bishop and I have a G file and I'm
threatening throwing stuff this could be
coming
first I wasn't too scared of that the
now I'm realizing King f8 Queen h6 kind
of annoying
Keeney 7 queen a3
so maybe 97 97 laughs be careful of
taking and then 95 so I have to allow
something here
weights let's actually do some
calculation ke7 Queen a three Queen g6
we trade and then how does he defend
like night h4 actually looks nice King
e7 doesn't look like the safest place
for the king but at the same time likes
King isn't entirely safe this might need
some defending if Queen III probably
this way Queen III Queen b7 Queen a3
King at six
okay so we're going into this line I
guess White House Queen the e3 here or
Queen c3 but then Queen d5 it's actually
very interesting we imagine like Queen
c3 Queen d5 I don't know how white
defends everything maybe Bishop t1 now
you want wouldn't be playable guess
where it takes you too
the god of counterplay I haven't heard
that in a long time but things are going
well good to see you and singer so this
is a line I was kind of hoping for king
h1 is a move
we might get some like very strategic
endgame coming up so I could take on f3
and just have better structure let's do
it should be a nice I'm game lesson
because I have I just have better at
peace activity and I have a passed pawn
white has just a number of weaknesses
can take on d4 takes on each sevens do
this if he wants to defend f3 then
Bishop e4 is necessary but then I have
f5 and the only way for the Bishop to
stay defending r3 is to do this but then
I think I just dropped the bishop with
rookie 7:00 so I'll win the bishop or
I'll win f3 or all in both or all maybe
mate eventually and all the goal is to
push upon like the king is completely
stuck this Knight can't really be
removed so I wants to do this
wait I don't want to lose outside let's
just take the pond why not
maybe this threatening made in one no
that's not made in much because King g2
forgot the Knights would no longer
control g2 after it moves oh where is my
trick I mean this is completely winning
it's just a matter of converting in a
nice fashioned I chopped the bishop tick
around the bishop bishop c2 here in
Bishop a4 I can win off to then
forgot about that move okay let's just
clean things up and corrode upon but
what has been resisting who does two
fighting experience
I don't need my EEP on the only thing I
need is a seep on wait what's going on
let's do this and then I have talked to
b3 and then I can Sigma zigzag my way
down a and B file
if I didn't have an F pawn maybe it
could be interesting but okay
good game I mean I kind of wish my
opponents yeah I think taking on h8 is
the best move to and then it's probably
best for me to keep Queens on the board
and this would have been so much fun I
clean up before so race still checkmate
I'd be threatening this maybe develop my
queen battery I could maybe have like a
triple battery someday don't often see a
triple battery on a diagonal what what
would stock fish say about this position
it would probably just be terribly
confused but let's see why it's probably
better I would guess but probably not a
decisive advantage plus for stock fish
kills all the fun
+7 it just calculate some meat 9595 his
Bishop a4 is almost unstoppable
ok good thing my opponent didn't go for
this
+7 so unexpected so it'd be better for
me to take on d1 yeah and of course like
if this were a tournament game I mean I
should take on g7 and just be much
better but yeah the possibility of
having four Queens on the board too
tempting any other opening suggestions
opening suggestions Hey 505 subs nice
well I make a course on two nights
attack or Bowl might I make a video on
two nights attack I'm actually
considering making a course it's in the
works
oh wow there's a lot more opening
suggestions English opening Polish
opening Icelandic gambits Marinka to
with a sub what is this
wait let me add some stuff to the list
so English Icelandic before I liver bonk
loud I don't think so but maybe polish I
have no idea what the South African gam
it again I don't think I'm playing the
groud again I was way too stressful
London if you want the London just watch
any of my previous streams Traxler
exchange French
whoever said exchange French no but
maybe maybe I play the exchange French
once in a tournament I got a good
position but then I lost okay let's play
someone
[Music]
let's play the most appetizing name
which name is the most appetizing muscle
not excellent tea most of these are not
food
unicorn like a unicorn Frappuccino which
I never had because they discontinued it
Oh iced americano that looks most
advertising any other food names
monkey-do no we're gonna play iced
americano not something I usually drink
good luck
smoked brisket in the chat says I am the
most appetizing look at this look at
that look at that name smoked brisket ok
wait what were the d4 while these were
you four openings I need G four openings
Rob afraid liver London you know the
other Oh Dutch defense someone said okay
I'll play a dutch good luck I'm playing
a dutch playing the london this is what
i play against the Dutch so there's a
very specific way white should approach
playing Bishop f4
because it's always that easy to justify
because I'm gonna put my pawn on d6 I'm
going to employ this setup and then long
term I'll play e5 let's start with d6
nicely would play g4 against the Dutch
or just g4 and move one c3 okay so we
have various standard London
and yeah the actually the nice thing
about the Dutch if white doesn't like
challenge the setup right away
well at first like six or seven moves
are very easy to play and then the plan
applying e5 usually like 1976 sometimes
Queen e8 even so just to share when I'm
white and I play against the Dutch I
don't play an early c3 but I play an
early c4 and I would actually play an
early c4 and then c5 without 92 and it's
a very interesting line computer
approves also a bit off beats how many
people are Dutch in the chat like
actually Dutch see [ __ ] says hi I am
Dutch it took me a moment so I thought
that's your name but it's probably your
nationality there's a lot of weird
gambits against in Dutch it's daunting
gambit there's a G for gambit there's
this Bishop g5 we're in line
Queen e8 probability there's also not h5
let's play Queen units
if I can get any five then it just
facilitates like a nice nice King sight
pawn storm Queen c2 okay going for it
there's another opening recommendation
Blackmar Deemer gambit I'm not going to
get to all of these also for anyone
wondering how long the stream will last
it's going to last until then the canna
calls me because I need to pick up my
car at some points this afternoon which
could be soon or it could be much later
wowie for moving the pawn before I could
move ye pawn I mean I could respond with
e5 and then it's like Simon Says I could
wait I could take this bishops not
defended anymore so there might be some
tactics
this is where calculation comes into
play so takes takes takes takes I want
to deflect the queen from defending the
bishop but if I do this and takes with
check
so there's another move here night each
five just attacking the bishop if Bishop
e3 or g3 I play f4 you can also consider
a five and then there's this so when I
teach five actually looks most
attractive here let's play nine h5
my opponent is watching if he was
watching realize I said f4 chops of
bishop but does a trap the bishop pretty
sure traps the bishop my opponent is
saying no with three o's maybe that
signifies his next move or maybe it's a
gambit
it's only a GABA that fight wins white
loses it's just a blunder yeah neither
for this is nice targeting G to split
the King on each eights
okay now it's time to attack I already
have a knight here
I'm thinking about speaking of gambits
like gambling a pawn and if a knight
takes I play this let's do it
it might be a bluff but it might be just
a good line for me see what happens
people still recommending openings I
have a very long list you guys want to
see my list look at this Grob laughs Ian
Oh both of those I played Saturday
dragon scotch English Icelandic fried
liver blonde cloud polish I think
someone said alekhine and it was a [ __ ]
yeah Albin Cara gave it to many to to
write down
okay so the knight is attacked it's also
pinned because g2 is a mating square and
it's a sub do the black Mart Deemer
before the rest something something says
high UV black mare Deemer is actually
quite playable like it does it's not too
contingent on what the whole in place if
I'm white
Halloween gambit
I played the Halloween gamete in my
match against Pat a GM Papac wanker I
forgot the results I think we drew but
like I sacked the night and then he
immediately sacked it back and it was
just kind of equal but then I play the
Halloween gab it's a couple days ago and
some lits tournaments it was so
beautiful such my Center I love light
can save the peace here because if h4 I
play each six if 93 I still play h6
is it actually playable and lit slash
bullets the Halloween gambit yeah
especially in bullets pretty sure
there's a refutation there's like some
weird refutation which is impossible so
I like figure out unless Wu can take the
night unless you're prepared with like
stock fish but then there's a very
practical like continuation so g3o the
pawns pins is so the only thing that's
attacked is my rook d5 is kind of a
attractive move because there are so
many pins and counter pins like this has
pinned the pawn is pinned to the Queen
yeah those are the pins I'm attacking
the bishop - and soon soon I just want
to go for like some crazy attack bring
my knight into play bring my bishop into
play
we'll see what white does just one note
and this should go without saying but if
you keep saying like play me play me in
the chat I probably won't play you or
will be less incentivize up like you but
okay for the next one I'll have to pick
like some category of username because
this this guy it was the most
advertising to figure out some other
category the most colorful the heaviest
oh the dog behind me is is my dog if you
all see more pictures of my dog you can
follow me on Instagram Bishop b3 yeah
let's just bring more pieces towards the
kingside putting pressure on the pinned
pawn
so this is an amazing thing I am almost
out of tea but look at this I have this
and I just pour and it's more tea kind
of cold at this point but it's still
okay so the position is good the time is
good material is good the tea is good
life is good I'm thinking about making
because I've been seeing other people do
this let's play Bishop f5 I have all my
pieces single-file line like grade
school what was I saying
oh I'm thinking about making a merch
I've been holding off because I don't
want to just sell a random stuff but
honestly it would just be for me to make
like a mug that says life is good and so
is tea should make that
okay there has to be I mean all
eyepieces are on the kingside I want to
play rook a fades just for a troll but
now let's go for some mating attack
looking for a meeting ideas like this
friends made in one SS idea both my
Knights are kind of sort of attacked
like pawns let's go here my opponent
says I know if I should say what he said
but I'll say it cuz it's ironic says I'm
so embarrassed that might make him even
more embarrassed I don't know I came up
with a joke yesterday I haven't
delivered it yet but maybe now is a good
time what do you call it when you
embarrass yourself doing puzzle rush
puzzled blush okay let's get this game
over with assuming I can deliver meat in
a better way than I can deliver a joke
I'm hoping that she takes off for his
plane so now I have 93 discovered attack
and just force mates if he doesn't take
the night I'll probably have this idea I
also have these ideas I want to I can
bring though they're broken to play
should play the Ducks more often whoever
suggested the Dutch thanks for
suggesting it my jokes rating is 900 900
is not bad that's like it's better than
most people on the planet chat disaster
- wait I didn't read most of the chat oh
no did I just lose all my followers I
think I lost all my followers I'm so
sorry
but it would be funny to just start from
scratch like just start with like a
clear slate oh wait current follower
account
ten thousand and ninety okay good I
didn't he'll lose all my followers so
we're lining up on the fourth rank now
if the knight moves I made it basically
in one if the pawn takes a knight I have
this king h1 okay
let's do don't want to do waiting at age
three no let's just go for meat should
be enough the night spins so it's not
depending upon h4 hey it's another sub
get your neck OHS here thanks for
subbing I'm looking for a mate where
let's play hit this I'm putting all my
pieces on light squares but more
importantly I'm attacking the Knights I
want to play rook takes now it's a
question will my horn your flag resign
or get mated stick with the rook
I'm still looking for a forcemeat I mean
okay there's countless ways to win but I
want to do it like forcing leaning takes
my bishops let's just take the bishop no
need to calculate okay time is common
nice game
it feels like bug house or crazy house
where you just like to start putting
pieces like all around the king but that
was chess that was a fun one yeah I
think white-white should be okay after
even after Knight h5 Bishop c4 is an
interesting move to throw in there is
also some idea
playing Bishop g3 well enough for and
then Bishop h4 should be playable okay
so I know people want to play of any
contact from the mechanic doesn't look
like it no okay so what is this
okay sixty pending challenges oh wait we
need a category give me a category
someone let's let's do the heaviest like
what would be the heaviest thing out of
all these user names Jack running it's
like a hundred twenty pound no 150
pounds a lot of these don't have weight
values monkeys our monkeys could be
heavy Lord nukes a lot alpha G horse
lasagna what does that mean absolute
units
yeah I think I have to play horse
lasagna
that sounds really heavy horse lasagna
good luck 10 minute game was there drama
llama I miss drama llama skimming
through wait what opening do I play
notes Polish fried liver okay let's play
let's play e4 and see where it leads I
will have any opening recommendations
against a French but someone was asking
earlier about two Knights attack so I'm
playing a tonight's attack Sicilian
someone was asking earlier about Marazzi
bind it's a great thing about like so
many people suggesting openings and all
these transposed in today something
someone suggested so this is actually
the last game of the World Championship
the last wrapping game Carlson played D
for here I usually like to play Knight
c3 because my c3 I think it's Knights
I know it's Bishop e2 I'm gonna play d4
more more typical Marazzi Pines Carlson
played this incredibly well like he gave
Fabiano nothing and then just one now in
this specific variation white does need
to be careful because there's ideas of
like for black playing Knight f6 and
Bishop b4 g6 is another move that is
usually very good especially when you
already committed to e6 I think I'll
just go ahead and play d5
very typical and Sicilian if black
doesn't take on d4 and d5 causes
problems the problem with committing to
e6 and g6 are the darks rays and this is
a free pawn just block to hear f6 or
Queen f6 if Queen f6 for a knight f6
I'll play e5 if f6 I'll just enjoy life
maybe h4 or f4 gain space
very unfortunate position for black so
Knight f6 so II five is one
consideration there's also Bishop g5 the
knight is only defended by the Queen so
there's some lion like Bishop g5 Bishop
d7 and d6 Queen a5 Bishop g2 let's do it
now if Bishop g7 Iove five there might
actually be a way for a block to survive
here I would be very impressed if black
finds it but it might involve Queen here
if I play Bishop d2 then the Queen was
back and like I wouldn't want to repeats
it's kind of hard to find mr. Frantz
here thanks for subbing let me move the
alert box up so it's not blocking that's
not letting me oh there we go okay so e5
my microphone - I think White's winning
a piece I feel my opponents pain but I
also feel my happiness
wait chat behave yourself
let's not get too graphic even if this
game is graphic doesn't mean you have to
be graphic in the chat apple mango
banana you have to sleep where are you
Asia probably Asia or Russia
wait Bishop d2 is it's probably what I
should play that's why Bishop d2 is
there anyone watching from Russia or
China then pretty sure twitches blocked
in China I can't remember having Russian
viewers know there's some other Russian
streamers though
yeah this is a good time to ask where is
everyone from Saudi Arabia Denmark
France Oh Chinese VPN for the wind nice
let's take the Queen and then take the
Knights Greece Greece Austria Iceland
Paris Ukraine Turkey Houston UK South
Carolina Croatia Norway Poland
Winchester UK Austria Canada Norway
Montreal Slovakia England France Ukraine
Belgium Antarctica Slovakia again Saudi
by then American Israel Hungary Germany
Holland Canada Brazil Proxima Centauri
Michigan Pakistan Brazil Greece Greece
st. Louis Wade st. Louis Missouri nice
Normandie Turkey India Spain Colorado
Arizona another mission mission
Michigander sound like Flanders
Indianapolis Napa California Austria of
Buffalo Serbia Norway Romania Georgia
chess coach Nets welcome to the chat
Texas Tunisia Cuba New Zealand Wisconsin
the dumpster outside the 7-eleven 660
seventh moon of Jupiter ok I think I
covered most people Gibraltar nice
Kansas City - my opponent has moved now
my mouth hurts I'm so much talking this
looks like a free pawn and now I'm
having some fork ideas
hmm okay
actually maybe I won't yeah I was
thinking maybe I should have considered
this or this but it shouldn't matter if
the grand scheme of things let's do this
I'm trying to provoke King G 8 and then
I want to migrate my Knights to e7
hey London nice Tennessee Cape Town cool
if I had to pick one of these places to
travel to Oh which one I would pick I'll
actually be going to Tennessee in a few
months
I would probably go back to London it's
a nice City London probably has like the
best food I've ever had even the fast
food places are amazing but then any
like sort of nice restaurant is just so
such good food okay I have a plan
also did my stream die why is my stream
being weird do people see this look at
that that's not a good sign that's not a
good sign at all
always play off three ooh this is a nice
move I have no idea if people can see
this it's laggy I deeply apologize can
you hear me hey it's green again look at
that okay he overcame a rough patch you
were losing me but now you're you're
winning me also I'm threatening made in
one and the bishop so f6 is played let's
take the pawn don't want to take the
bishop
the king is completely stuck I don't
know if I'm actually threatening
forcemeat but okay it's completely
winning probably my plan is to do this
and this and the stream is dead again
what is going on I'm so sorry
I don't know what to do the only thing I
know how to do is go for me okay it's
green again that's good and now it's
back to read too many different colors
okay so I'm threatening Lee I'm
threatening to mate actually this is
double checkmate I'm pretty sure I could
cream of this and just be mates yeah I'm
done with this game
yeah I probably have to call the
internet company because it shouldn't be
dying like this assuming people can
still hear me oh my dog might be
watching Netflix that's maybe the issue
I don't know I could restart the router
okay I think what I'll do is let's go to
the home page people see this look at
this there's two people streaming
there's about to be only one person
streaming last time I rage it last time
I rated Andrew Tang he said thanks
raisin because he wanted to say thanks
for the raid but he also wanted to say
thanks rosin so raid penguin gm1 good
bye guys
you